I think there's been a slightly
deplorable tendency amongst marks
biographers to paint
ah the human being in a very
complimentary light to imply that great
music requires a great man and a great
human being and a great personality to
be behind it well of course great music
requires a creator ad but it doesn't
have to be a paragon he doesn't have to
be a paragon of virtue and bark
certainly wasn't the more that one
discovers about him that the more one
discovers that he was a deeply flawed
character that even though we have very
very few family records and letters to
go on there are incidents that keep
cropping up in his life almost a
repetitive pattern of antagonistic
behavior between him and authority the
authorities for whom he worked he was
very competitive he mean he really took
them on but I think we can trace it back
really to his his earliest times all
right he started off in a presumably
very happy family situation with both
parents living but he didn't go to
school very often we have a lot of
records of truancy now why what was it
why was he not at school
that's one big question then comes the
double shock of both parents dying
before his ten and his upheaval rooted
as he was in eisenach he's now uprooted
and he goes to live with his elder
brother Johann Christoph a few miles
away in odd roof and suddenly his grades
shoot up a reaction to his orphanhood
who knows but the more I've been able to
delve into the circumstances in the
context of his schooling the worse it
becomes it looks as if the schools both
the first two schools that he was
involved in were prone to very modern
sounding difficulties of you know
overcrowding in classrooms shortage of
text
books hooliganism in the classroom
lobbing of bricks through windows
chasing of the girls coming to school
with daggers and spears and a good deal
of unpleasant bullying and sadistic
behavior there was one particular school
master of barks when he was in odd roof
and he was probably then only about 11
or 12 who was known as as the the bully
and the sadist of the school and
eventually he got handed his cards and
he left but not before inflicting
god-knows-what damage on his pupils and
this is that this is a theme that goes
all the way through bar schooling and we
can't say with assurance well he was
damaged but it does come out in certain
ways in for example in his very first
job that was when he was organist in an
start he gets into a quarrel with a
bassoonist
he writes a piece of music with a rather
difficult a couple of riffs for the
bassoon and the bassoonist obviously
makes a complete mess of it he can't
handle it so bark swears at him and
calls him something pretty rude and the
guy reacts by setting upon him in the
market square he comes at him with a
cudgel and bark draws his sword and
defends himself and there's tremendous
fisticuffs which is only broken up by
the onlookers and bark goes off to his
employers and says what's all that you
know you've got to protect me and they
don't that leads to a feeling of
suspicion of authority that runs right
the way through his life and it comes up
again and again and again and that comes
into the foreground when he's working
environment for the two Dukes the Duke
will him Ernst and his nephew who share
the the authority and bark is unhappy
there he feels he's been passed over for
the succession to become Kapellmeister
he feels aggrieved he looks for another
job he's appointed
and he doesn't get permission from the
Dukes to leave so they throw him into
prison and for a month
he's disgraced and imprisoned it doesn't
happen again as far as we know but he's
picking fights pretty much all the way
through his life and unnecessarily right
towards the end of his life when he's
achieved the most extraordinary quality
of and of his output including you know
the two passions the art of fugue the
well-tempered clavier all the
Brandenburg Concertos this fantastic
body of cantatas he picks a fight which
doesn't isn't even on his patch it's
down the road where a headmaster of a
school says there shouldn't be too much
music in his business in this school of
mine anymore the emphasis should be on
the academic curriculum and barque calls
the headmaster which in German is
wrecked or he calls him dreck or played
a pun a very school boyish pun on words
and preg or means dirty ear why did he
get himself involved unnecessarily and
all that it's as though he couldn't
resist it so I think it would be a great
mistake to try and align this concept of
divine music and divine human being
behind it and in fact I would say the
opposite the very fact that this music
is so profound and so uplifting and the
man is clearly not a saint makes it all
the more interesting
it makes it much more human and make
much more approachable
you